et un des sujets du jour voilà tout le
monde en a parlé on va évoquer le cas
Guillaume Meuris al je sais pas si vous
savez qui est Guillaume Meuris c'est un
humoriste de France interre apparemment
il a suscité un tolé après une chronique
dans laquelle moi j'écoute jamais France
interre je suis désolé les chéris voilà
j'écoute pas j'ai voilà j'écoute pas du
tout après il y a des bonnes choses hein
mais c'est vrai que là vraiment je crois
que c'était le dimanche hein c'est ça ou
c'est vrai j'écoute pas beaucoup la
radio le dimanche puisque je suis en
train de de de de de faire du sport bien
entendu euh il compare donc Benjamin
nataniaou le Premier ministre israélien
a a une sorte de nazi sans prépus alors
il y a eu des réactions de partout euh
j'ai vu ça moi sur les réseaux que j'ai
regardé brièvement j'ai pas vu la
chronique vous allez réagir est-ce que
vous trouvez euh doit-il être suspendu
parce que il y en a plein qui demandent
sa suspension tiens il y a dphin
orviller l'excellent Delphin orviller
prépus ou pas moi je seraai plutôt en
faveur de circoncire le temps d'antenne
de Guillaume Meuris ça c'est drôle euh
voilà et puis il y en a plein qui ont
qui ont qui ont réagi Julien Bou aussi
un très bon journaliste qui a dit
netaniiaou une sorte de naz sans prépus
nous vons venir de vivre l'un des pires
progrommes antijuifs depuis la Choa et
tout ce que tu trouves à dire c'est de
qualifier le Premier ministre de l'État
juif de nazi son prépus il y a eu plein
de de de messages comme ça et il y a
Bruno gaasscio lui de son côté qui a dit
soutiens Guillaume meriss évidemment
l'humour la blague ça pique toujours un
peu c'est pour ça que c'est bon on rit
tous un jour de quelque chose qui fait
de la peine à un autre qui le choque
c'est la fonction de l'humour l'arcom a
été saisi alors les pauvres l'arcom dès
qu'il y a un truc tout le monde saisit
l'arcom c'est un truc de fou voilà tu
dis non mais c'est vrai que l'arcom à un
moment ils doivent avoir des dossiers
toute la journée non mais il y a un mec
qui a dit j'aime pas les pains au
chocolat sur France 2 et un autre gars
qui voilà et ça c'est vrai que ça fait
énormément réagir je vais découvrir euh
la chronique comme vous peut-être que
vous si vous l'avez pas vu vous nous
dites ce que vous en pensez est-ce qu'il
doit être suspendu de France interre et
on a envie d'avoir également votre avis
chez vous à 20h22 on est en direct c'est
parti alors halloween halloween approche
et tout le monde commence à chercher un
déguisement pour faire peur alors en ce
moment il y a le déguisement néthaniaaho
qui marche pas mal pour faire peur vous
voyez qui c'est une sorte de nazi mais
sans prépus voilà alors il fait pas peur
à il fait pas peur à tout le
monde alors euh
oui vous pensez qu'il doit être suspendu
s'il vous plaît prenez vos petites
manques même pas suspendu virez virez
sur le champ virez sur le champ non mais
l'antisémitisme c'est pas une opinion
c'est un délit donc sur une radio
publique énoncer ça qui est purement et
simplement une injure antisémite c'est
une honte c'est un scandale je ne
comprends même pas que la direction ne
l'est pas virer sinédiier sur le champ
pour faute grave où ça sur le champ ah
merci immédiatement C sinédié oui oui
sur le champ tout de suiteou GG tu dis
non non parce que moi je suis pour la
liberté d'expression même si elle
dérange même si je la trouve nulle même
si je la trouve choquante en fait vous
trouvez ça pas drôle mais pas chocant en
fa non si bien sûr que je trouve ça
chocant je trouve ça évidemment très
très choquant mais en fait je veux que
ce soit la loi qui passe c'està-dire que
si la loi estime que c'est antisémite je
veux qu'il soit condamné mais je ne veux
pas moi être redressur s de tort et dire
c'est antisémite et je veux qu'il soit
exclu de l'antenne ce qui me choque
c'est qu'il fait qu'il fasse ça sur le
service public et le service public en
fait aujourd'hui utilise le rire à des
fins idéologiques donc ça ça me choque
je trouve que c'est un scandale et
effectivement à titre personnel dans un
contexte où il y a un pogrom comme
jamais depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
dans un contexte où il y a les actes
antisémites qui explosent en France et
d'ailleurs partout dans le monde dans un
contexte donc très électrique je trouve
que voilà en fait nazifier aujourd'hui
enfin les les Juifs en fait je trouve
que c'est juste un scandale absolu mais
je ne veux pas qu'il soit condamné parce
que je ne veux pas le victimiser et je
veux pas qu' après les gens de la France
insoumise disent aux Juifs qui disent ça
à c'est pour ça moi alors jeanmille toi
tu trouves que il faut bah oui parce que
je comprends pas gine tu dis que c'est
pas drôle c'est choquant bah je sais pas
quand tu quand tu fais une telle faute
professionnelle ça mérite une sanction
franchement sur surtout service
publicure de Hebdo donc je vais pas je
vais pas lui l'interdire deô c'est pas
c'est pas Charlie Hebdo
c'est
la passe tu n pas la je suis pas la lo
il faut que la lo passe et si la lotime
ou
si que justement il a il a fait quelque
chose qui n'est pas bien à ce moment il
est condamné mais pas nous parce queon
est la moralité c'est important quand
même les Juifs à les
anciamn aura touour des gens choqués ou
pas choqués bien sûr que c'est déulasse
je je ne veux pas moi me substituer à la
justice moi je trouve que tu attises la
haine en c'est lui qui atse toi lui il
attise la haine je trouve en sortant des
blagues comme ça qui sont pas drôles et
qui
sont mais SAF que si on l'écarte ce sera
encore pire dans le contexte actuel si
on l'écarte on va le victimiser ça sera
encore plus
catastrop don récompense alors
Jean-Michel tu parles de je pense pas
qu'on pas avir le mot moral actuellement
je trouve que ce mec fait son métier à
partir de ce momentl si vous voulez pas
que les humorist F un métier ben pendant
les temps de guerre vous dites aux
humoristes d'arrêter de faire de
l'humour et si lui doit être puni alors
il va falloir punir beaucoup de
personnes ch dire on a le droit d'être
choquéons j'ai pas dit pas le droit
d'être choqué mais si on vire celui-là
il va falloir virer Zemour il va falloir
virer ARN humiste mais pe importe pe
importe le rapport c'est que lui en tout
cas quand il fait il fait de l'humour et
il y en a d'autres qui sont sérieux et
qui blessent donc je suis désolé cette
personne là elle a sa place ça c'est pas
blessant ça c'est pas blessant pas dit
c'était pas blessant mais c'est pas au
point de le il fait son métier méti son
métier c'est d'être antisémite c'est ça
c'est son métier an il est pas
antisémitez qu've dis il a dit que le
premier ministre israélien était un a a
combien rigol il en a combien qui on
rigolé dans la salle il y a trop de
crétins qui on rigolé dans la salle mais
tout le monde est choqué non mais c'est
une horreur absolu là vous êtes
complètement dingue de tolérer ça
d'ailleurs non mais vous tous vous
pouvez pas tous ceux qui mettent non
enfin alors mainant alors maintenant on
va sur les ones de service public on est
antisémite moi je pense moi je pense
qu'avant tout Guillaume Meuris n'est pas
drôle c'est ça
oui il n'est pas drôle du tout voilà il
a jamais été drôle voilàand tu dis quand
tu dis mundir guillaumeurce n'est pas
antis pasôè
aprè pardon parce que quand quand des
proches par exemple fait un sketch qui
est absolument formidable ou des proches
rentrent sur scène et dit il y a des
Juifs dans la salle il retourne la salle
et il fait mourir de rire la salle parce
qu'on on a aucun doute sur
l'murs on aucun doute à ce momentl
sur attends je termine Guillaume Mace
moi j'ai un doute pardon j'ai le droit
d'avoir le doute et quand par par
ailleurs tu nazifies les Juifs qui est
quand même le truc de l'inversion
l'inversion de de la charge accusatoire
qui est quand même folle c'estàdire que
la victime devient le bourreau c'estàd
le Juif devient le nazi on marche sur la
tête et qu'en plus tu essentialises le
juif en disant que le Juif c'est celui à
qui manque un prépu pardon mais moi
quand quand tu décortiques le truc ça
fait un peu froid dans le dos et ça fait
un peu après moi je dis qu'il faut pas
le virer de l'antenne parce que encore
une fois j'ai pas du tout envie c'est ce
que je dis parce que j'ai pas du tout
envie que justement il se victim
zif on tellouir on réussi faire
l'antenne j'ai pas envie de l'avir en
position de victime parce adore être en
position de victime donc voilà pour la
raison pour laquelle je dis ça mais mais
l'humour ça marche un quand c'est drôle
là effectivement tu as des gens qui ont
ri mais parfois tu as des gens qui
risent sur des chos qui qui m'étonne et
tu as raison quand ça pique il faut que
ça pique même c'est pas
très est-ce do être sctionné par l'arcom
par le gendarme de
l'audiovisuel je comend parce que le
critère c'est pour les uns c'est
l'humour pour les autres c'est
l'antisémitisme enfin mais il fait son
métier mais il fait pas un métier là il
est en train de prononcer quelque chose
d'antisémite c'est c'est condamnable par
la justice c'est tout et je comprends
pas je comprends pas ton
discours d'aller jusquau ton discours
qui consiste à dire la justice doit
passer mais en même temps moi je veux
pas me substituer à la justice justice
on parle là
de qu' doit êre sorti de l'antenne doit
s parce qu'on a sorti des gens de
l'anten pour beaucoup moins que ça je ve
dire nous on a pris des amendes on a
pris des amendes énormes je vous dire
moi je le dis ce soir si si a et les mec
on a pris les mecs il faut savoir on a
pris on a pris même des amendes de de
300000 € parce qu'on avait un logo sur
le truc donc si lui il s'en sort et
c'est eux il s'en sortent à à moins d'un
million d'euros c'est vraiment qu'il y a
vraiment deux poids de mesure et ça sera
très très grave et je le dis hein parce
queah quoi bah oui ben les 1 million
d'euros c'est les l'État c'est les
Français qui vont les donner puis c'est
le service public pas du tout qui vont
attaquer c'est pour ça que j'ai mis non
moi je veux qu'on l'attaque lui je veux
pas que ce soit France Inter moi je veux
qu' reste à
l'antenneiteur
qui France ils ont envie d'assumer ses
propos à lui laissant on s'en fout ils
ont un budget France interre ils
viendont viendront taper dedans 2
milliion ils vont voir ce que ça va
faire je dire ils s'en fout pas du tout
France interre France France 3 France 2
qu qu' en on à fout il des programes à
l'antenne c'est c'est des catastrophes
industrielles y a quelqu'un qui dit ça
aurait ét P vous soutiz
t ce qui pire c'est cet antisémitisme
mondain qui sous couvert de de de BL
motage on est dans le sillage de la
France insoumise on est dans le sillage
de l'islamo gauchisme et tout passe et
le pire c'est qu'ici vous êtes tr/4 à
dire non il doit pas être sanctionné bah
attendez revenez un peu à la vraie
échelle des valeurs pardon mais il y a
des mecs qui se font virer pour faire
des blagues dégueulasses et débiles sur
des femmes là il s'agit d'antisémitiste
c'est tout simplement Pun alors il y a
des gens qui réagissent sur les réseaux
il y a des gens qui réagissent sur les
réseaux il a fait d'autres sketch
maintenant qui ressort cment regardez
voilà on va voir des photos de Guillaume
je sais pas si il les ont voilà
notamment voilà par de dout sur sur
Guillaume me l' invité je crois cette
occasion
justement c'est dans l'émission de
Charline là ce qu'il a fait du dimanche
soir Charline avait dessiné une
moustache d'Hitler sur une affiche d'éc
Zemour elle avait déjà nazifié un juif
donc moi je trouve qu'il faut pas se
tromper de débat c'est pas si tu veux ah
mais c'est un métier l'humour et donc
grâce à l'humour on peut tout faire et
on peut tout dire non non mais tu c'est
ça le vrai le vrai sujet pas humoriste
par exemple non je suis pas humoriste je
l'ai vu moi en spectacle en r humorist
bon il m'a fait rire la moitié du temps
la première demi-heure après je trouvis
ça très long et assez insupportable mais
surtout je trouve que l'humour ne permet
pas tout voilà et je trouve que dès
l'instant où on tombe dans quelque chose
qui est juste condamnable par la justice
en ce moment et ben il doit être d'abord
sanctionné parors Daniel toi tu dis non
do sanction je dis non mais je voudrais
expliquer pas drôle et choquant c'est
quand même exactement les couvertures de
Charlie Hebdo chaque chaque Mo donc on
va
inter voilà mais et moi je suis je
trouve que ce serait même une sanction
en de ça de ce qu'il mérite c'est pour
ça que je mets non c'est pas du tout r
comis il mérite beaucoup plus que juste
être suspendu alors déjà moi ce que je
voudrais préciser c'est que AR AR cl ce
matin a dit qu'il avait eu CB vel qui
est la présidente de Radio France au
téléphone qu'elle n'avait pas du tout
aimé cette blague CB V c'est quand même
la femme d'un des petits fils de Simone
ve je pense qu'elle aurait pu condamner
publiquement cette cette blague qu'elle
apprécie pas et qui est très grave ça
c'est dans un premier temps et ensuite
moi je suis pour que la loi vraiment
passe Gill William goldanel l'avocat va
porte plainte contre Guillaume humist et
je pense qu'il faut que ça aille au-delà
parce que je suis désolé mais la liberté
d'expression c'est un humorist après
après il y a des photos alors il y a
plein de photos qui ressortent avec
Philippe Poutou exactement maintenant
voilà donc là ben outrême gauche il se
veut il se revendique très à GAE
d'ailleurs et sous couvert de ça ce qui
est une honte la justice elle va aussi
prendre en compte l'attitude de
l'éditeur si l'éditeur enfin en
l'occurrence France Inter ou la la
présidente de Radio France décide d'une
sanction ce sera mis à d'une certaine
façon enfin ça peut un peu atténuer les
choses bah oui c'est ça va prendre des
mois c'est maintenant qu'il faut le
virer la justice on s'en fout
là c'est son employeur qui doit le virer
de suite c'est pas suspendu qu'on
ve c'est demand mais les chéri moi je
comprends pas ce que vous dites là là
c'est une émission elle est en direct
cette émission ou elle est
enregistrée non mais les gars France
interre ils doivent prendre une sanction
je suis désolé les gars il faut arrêter
un moment lui qui soit viré oui mais qui
ils doivent prendre une sanction France
interre avec tous les signalement qui a
l'arcom do prendre une sanction de 2 3
millions d'euros et on va le vérifier je
il il a répondu en mettant en mettant un
un teet avec un lien pour un
documentaire qui qui qui est un
documentaire sur brassins et il reprend
la phrase de la chanson de brassins
pourtant je ne fais de mal à personne
bah si tu fais du mal à ça a fait du mal
à des gens donc il fait simpl ne
pas qu'en ce moment je vous le dis je
trouve
que et c'est pas du tout le moment je
vais vous en parler d'ailleurs dans
uninstant ce qu'on voit on va en parler
tout ce qui s'est passé et pu c'est pas
très courageux aussi parce qu'il risque
pas de pour sa vie en faisant ça ou oui
mais toute
façon mal parlé de moi un jour je l'ai
appelé j'ai pas senti le gars voilà j'ai
pas senti très courageux non plus voilà
Guillaume c'est pas un gars
c'est quelqu'un qui est très politisé
moi j'ai vu son spectacle il est très
très politisé
fautend terroriste et tout ça donc ça
c'est complètement logique par rapport à
ce qu'il pense alors il il y en a qui
disent aussi il a critiqué natthaniaou
et non pas les Juifs qu'est-ce que vous
répondz à ça ou non mais là c'est c'est
netanah le premier ministre d'Israël non
mais c'est pour moi l'argument ne tient
pas c'est escalité il critique le
Premier ministre d'Israël quoi qu'on en
pense c'està-dire la fonction de l'homme
qui gouverne en Isra donc derri tout ça
critiquer aujourd'hui le premier
ministre d'Israël sur ce tonl c'est
justement pervers c'est-à-dire queil
pensait que ça passerait parce que c'est
pas les juif mais le Premier ministre
pour moi c'est pire par H prier ministre
ISEN il il a dans l'opinion publique il
il est il est voilà
il il incarne les Juifs pour le grand
public le grand public quand tu dis
netanahou d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
reproche ceux qui n'aiment pas les Juifs
reprochent en faisant une une sorte de
de de d'amalgame entre le gouvernement
israélien Israël les Juifs les
Israéliens et ce donc tout ça c'est le
symbole du
Ju je sais mais il y a des gens qui
disent il y a beaucoup de Juifs qui sont
pas d'accord avec
la d'ailleurs la de char regardez la Une
de Charli Hebdo s'il vous plaît mettez
là s'il vous plaît assez vite soyez un
peu plus Israël les familles en otage en
colère les Juifs commencent à me faire
chier donc Natania et voilà donc cette
une montre que voilà
même s manifestation n is est très
fortte c très fort la politique c'est
drôle et c'est de la politique lui il
est pas drôle il fait pas de politique
c'est de l'insulte l' et c'est c'est un
humour moi pour moi ça me fait pas rire
mais je dire c'est une attaque en
fonction de sa religion pas en fonction
de sa politique pas en fonction de son
action politique et il faut faire la
différence il aurait critiqué son action
pas de problème il peut faire toutes les
blagues qu'il veut mais pas quand ça
renvoie à ton origine ou ta religion on
va revenir làdessus enfin pas là-dessus
d'ailleurs parce que c'est on va voir
j'aimerais voir le sondage s'il vous
plaît merci ou là merci oui 41 % non à
58% doit-il être suspendu non à 58 %
donc c'est un petit peu ce qui se
passait ici hein euh voilà euh